[Music]
today we're going to take a look at ng
XS a new state management library that
reimagines the way the Redux pattern
should be applied and angular it gives
us a global and mutable data store then
components can select data from the
store as an observable then dispatch
actions to mutate the store the end
result is a circular predictable flow of
data that is especially beneficial for
apps that have a complex data state in
this episode we'll go through the basics
of ng XS from the ground up if you're
new make sure to LIKE and subscribe and
grab the full source code from angular
firebase comm so first we need to
address the elephant in the room there's
already a state management library for
angular called ng R X which has become
very popular by taking the
implementation details of react Redux
and applying them to angular but the
problem is that angular has a type
system and makes heavy use of
object-oriented programming while react
has no type system and makes heavy use
of pure functions in order to strong
type everything and maintain a strict
separation of concerns and ng Rx we have
to write a ton of boilerplate code code
that is often very difficult to read
especially for someone without an rxjs
background while I'm a big fan of ng rx
and one of its top donors I think ng XS
addresses some of these concerns in a
very elegant way so what I've done for
this video is I built an app with ng XS
and then I built the same exact app with
ng Rx so we can compare them
side-by-side
the rest of this video will focus on the
basics of ng XS but occasionally I'll
flip over to this ng rx app just so you
can see that differences and how the
code is implemented and I'm not
recommending one over the other just
showing you a comparison between the two
the app itself is called ng XS salad bar
and it allows the user to create and
customize a salad order if you look at
the UI here you'll see everything
highlighted in green is saved in the app
store and everything with a solid
outline border is triggering an action
so you can see here we trigger actions
that add toppings to the salad and then
it computes the price in response to
those actions to get started we'll
generate a new angular app with the CLI
then we'll install ng XS store and also
a couple plugins for development so we
can
Redux dev tools or console.log state
changes directly in the browser the next
step is to go into the app module and
import ng XS you'll also notice that
I've created a shared folder which is
where we're going to keep the app state
in the router state we're going to build
these out later but you can think of the
state as a combination of an ng rx
reducer and effect in a single class
then we'll import the state classes here
in the app module and add them to the ng
XS for route and then we'll also add our
ng XS plugins here as well then just a
quick side note the plug-in system is
really awesome because it allows you to
tap into the state changes and the
action that triggered them to extend the
library with your own custom
functionality
now just to do a quick comparison our
app module and ng rx would look more
like this where we have a storm module
for route with a couple of reducers and
then an FX for route with the effects
classes now back to our ng access app
we're going to build our first action
inaction is just a class that has a type
property and an optional payload the
only difference from an ng RX action is
that the type property is static using a
static property here is a clever way to
reduce boilerplate because we don't
actually have to instantiate an object
we can just pass in the class name when
dispatching an action now I'm going to
jump into the app state and that's where
all the action happens the very first
thing we'll do is model our data as an
interface which should look very
familiar if you use ng Rx for the app
state will set a username order ID and a
status the next step is to drop in the
state decorator which replaces a reducer
and ng rx it's a class decorator and we
can strong type it to the interface that
we just defined then we'll give the
state a name so we can slice it from the
global store based on that name so this
will be our app slice and we can also
pass it some default values in this case
I just give it an empty string and a
random number as the order ID so as you
can see here we now have a slice of the
state that's clearly defined with
default values the next thing we'll want
to do is listen to
actions and then handle them as they're
dispatched for that we have this action
decorator that takes the action class as
its argument in our case set username
then you define a method to handle this
action the first argument in this method
is the state context which allows us to
get and mutate the state within this
method in this case here I'm going to
use patch state to update a single
property in the state without updating
other items then the second argument is
the action which may or may not have a
payload in this case it has the username
as its payload at this point we want to
update the current state with the new
username and we can do that by calling
patch state with The Associated data in
ng rx normally you would compose a new
object by using the spread syntax inside
your reducer function but here we're
calling patch state which does the same
thing under the hood but makes our code
a lot more readable and there's actually
a few other tricks that we can do within
the state context patch state will only
update the properties that are specified
but if we want to update everything
within the context of this slice of the
state we can call set state and that
will reset the state to the new
specified object we can also dispatch
other actions from inside this action
which is especially useful when you
start working with asynchronous data and
the other thing you can do is you can
get the current state as a plain object
let's say we want to look at the current
user before we actually update their
user name we just call get state and
that gives us this slice as a plain
object now let's quickly run through a
more concrete example let's say we have
an action that navigates with the
angular router first we'll set up an
action called navigate with a static
read-only type and the payload is the
actual path that we want to navigate to
then we'll set up our state to just be a
string where the value represents the
actual path that the user had navigated
to then we can inject the angular router
directly into our state which is a
really awesome feature of ng XS one
thing that you really miss in a reducer
function is the ability to use angular's
dependency injection and yet another
cool feature is that we're not just
limited to observables the angular
router returns a promise when we
navigate so we can actually just make
this an async phone
then await the router navigation and
update the state afterwards async/await
provides huge gains and code readability
and avoids the callback hell that you
would normally have in an NG rx effect
for dealing with a simple asynchronous
operation that's promise based that
being said you can still listen to a
stream of actions and handle them just
like you would in an NG rx effect what
you're looking at here with this route
handler is a stream of actions that is
filtered to our navigate action so you
do have the option to do things the ng
RX effects way if you prefer that and
there are certainly use cases for doing
so now that we have all this code in
place let's go into a component and look
at how we can select slices of the state
and dispatch actions let's say we want
to select the app state in our app
component the most familiar way to do it
is to declare a property and then inject
the store in the constructor and then
call store select and use a callback
function to select that slice of the
store so that's all good but in a second
here I'm going to show you a much better
way to do this with an NG access select
decorator but first I want to show you
how you can dispatch actions to do that
you can simply call stored dispatch and
then either pass in a single action or
an array of multiple actions in this
case we want to set the user name and
then navigate to our lazy loaded module
that's cool but let's see if we can make
some of this code magically disappear
let's delete everything from the
constructor and instead we'll use the
select decorator and then point to a
property of app followed by a dollar
sign by convention the library will
automatically look for a property named
app - the dollar sign on the root Store
and that's all you have to do to get
observable data from the store but if
that's a little too magical you can
still pass a function in to select a
slice as well the next thing I want to
show you is how to set up lazy loading
which is really easy to do with ng XS
after the user selects a name for their
order it's going to redirect them to a
lazy loaded route and update the state
with this new data if we look at the app
routing module you can see that we have
a lazy loaded salad module in order to
get this working we just need to tell ng
XS which state to use inside
is lazy module in this case we'll call
ng excess module for feature and then
pass it the solid state for this lazy
module the implementation details for
the lazy module are very similar to what
we set up in the app but I still want to
show you how selectors work when we need
to select complex slices of the state
this is common when you have to do
things like client-side filtering if you
imagine you have an array and you want
to sort it alphabetically or something
along those lines you can create a
selector by using this selector
decorator and then attach it to a static
method in this example we'll just do
something really simple like
transforming the dressing property to
locale uppercase now we can combine the
static method with our select decorator
in the actual component if you remember
the select decorator takes a function so
we can just pass it our class followed
by the function name and then that will
select that slice of the state in
whichever format we want it let's go
ahead and compare this code to ng our X
building the selector will look
something like this with ng XS on the
top and ng rx on the bottom we have the
functional approach on the bottom and
the object-oriented approach on the top
if you look at how we select state in
the component you can see we get by with
about 60% less code and ng XS the last
thing I want to show you is an
asynchronous action in ng XS jumping
back to the app component will create a
new action and pass at this confirm
order action class and then notice I'm
passing this cancel uncompleted true
option in the action decorator I'll show
you how this comes into play in just a
second inside this action itself we're
going to first patch the state with an
order status of pending then we'll
return an observable that represents the
async activity that we want to perform
that would most likely be an API call
over the network but in this case I'm
just returning a mock observable that
has a 50/50 chance of returning true or
false
inside the observable we'll pipe in the
tap operator if the observable resolves
are true then we'll go ahead and
dispatch the order success action
otherwise we'll dispatch or
failed now if we dispatch this action
it's going to subscribe to that
observable automatically
normally it would subscribe to every
single one and resolve to a value but
because we added the cancel uncompleted
true option in the action decorator it's
going to cancel all the previous
requests automatically let's say pretty
common requirement when you have
something like a type-ahead where you're
making multiple asynchronous API calls
and this is just one simple way that the
library tries to make things easier for
you I'm gonna go ahead and wrap things
up there if you have any questions or
want to see more energy excess content
please let me know in the comments
thanks for watching and I'll see you
soon